for some people that don't know if you
don't mind I had a chance to watch it
yesterday I know Charlie Kirks in it
Dennis prager's in it uh I want to say
almost everybody was in it I've had on
the podcast before but once you take a
minute and share with everybody what was
in 2000 meals
yeah so 2 000 meals is a is a movie
about election fraud and um it's not
kind of what you expect because right
after the 2020 election uh people raised
all kinds of issues they said oh isn't
it strange that Trump won these
Bellwether counties and he still won the
and still lost the election
um wasn't it strange that the the
counting and all the key States seemed
to stop at the same time and Trump was
winning the next morning whoa It's all
the opposite direction now these are
anomalies an anomaly is something
strange but by itself it doesn't prove
anything because there could be a
reasonable explanation
and uh so I stayed out of the election a
fraud debate for over a year
and then I was approached by a couple of
people who run an organization called
through the vote
uh and they they told me you know we
found an ingenious way to look at this
issue that no one has done before and uh
it's a combination of two things one is
cell phone Geo tracking which is of
course today a reliable technology used
by law enforcement used by the CIA used
by the CDC to monitor people's social
distancing
it's the tracking of your phone it's the
same technology that if you come to you
know go to Naples on vacation you get
off the plane they tell you the weather
is going to be really nice in Naples
well how they know you're there they're
tracking your phone and the other
um the second line of evidence is the
surveillance video of the states
themselves so a number of states not all
but some installed surveillance video
outside these mail and dropboxes
amazingly a year later no one had gone
back and looked at the footage it's
almost like having surveillance on a
bank there's the charge the bank's been
robbed but nobody bought it to go look
on the video so true the vote said look
we're going to show you some of the cell
phone Geo tracking we're going to show
you some of the video and and when I
looked at that I said to myself this is
a evidence of a completely different
caliber than I've seen before
um I don't know yet what it proves but
this is a way to go back you know we
were moving away from the election
this is a way to go back and look at the
actual cell phone movements of people
who are going to multiple drop boxes 10
10 or more 10 or more dropboxes now
remember that when you're talking about
a Dropbox we're not talking about the
mailbox somebody has a reason to go to a
mailbox many times right you can say I I
mailed my mortgage on Monday and then I
mailed my utility bill on Tuesday I
wrote my mom on Wednesday but a ballot
Dropbox you only have one reason to go
put ballots in it so if some guy's going
to 10 or more drop boxes it's hard to
think of a good explanation for why they
would do that so if you can use cell
phone tracking to find people who are
going in a short period right after the
election the few days up to the election
to 10 or more drop boxes that needs to
be investigated then let's just say that
we find you know Patrick your cell phone
you've gone to 10 or more dropboxes
and there are a couple of those
dropboxes that have video
so let's just say that we know that by
from your cell phone that you on
Election Day or the day before the
election were at all these drop boxes
and we actually know the time you got
there because it's from your phone so
now we go look on the video and there's
Patrick Bet David and what is he doing
you can see him on video he's putting
ballots into the box one two three four
five so this is evidence who has access
to this so the the states took the video
you can obtain the video through public
records that's how true the vote got it
you can get it there's not a person in
the country has said that's not the real
this is available to everybody if I
wanted to go get it tomorrow I could get
it yes okay perfect absolutely Freedom
of Information right that's what I'm
asking similarly with the cell phone Geo
tracking it's not known to people but
you can go now and buy the data let's
just say Atlanta the city of Atlanta you
can buy the data from October 1 to
November 8th Election Day 2020 right of
every cell phone in a What's called the
geofenced area you draw the app and
they'll give you that data you can buy
it and of course you need Specialists to
do a the proper kind of Investigation
but you can use that data to confirm or
undermine what we've been saying in this
film so that's the so the film operates
on those two lines of evidence and
that's what makes it remarkable that so
many people have tried to sort of
dismiss or debunk the film it's okay to
debate the film and it's okay to debate
the significance of what you're seeing
but to pretend like it's not relevant to
election fraud seems to me foolish so
let me ask you so here's a few questions
that would get me to think if there is
fraud going on out of all the videos
that were recording was there any City
or any area that wouldn't give you the
recording or was not somehow some way
available to see
yes so a number of areas did not take
video which is actually very bad because
think of it number one we live in a
country and at a time when technology is
cheap uh every Mall every parking lot is
under video right any is there any good
reason not to put a camera on a Dropbox
how many places were there was a lot of
places that was the necessary places the
majority of places did not have video at
all and they basically used the excuse
of covet they basically said oh you know
yeah we should but we never got around
to it so the only a few places that did
video and and even those places fight
you when you try to get the video they
don't make it easily available why not
um so this is right away a clue that
they're trying to block you from
watching what's on the video how long
have we been recording videos uh in
where people go and drop off their
ballots how long have we been recording
the history of recording videos
well here's the thing
it has been known for over I mean over
100 years that the vast majority of
election fraud occurs with absentee and
mail-in ballots and the reason is
obvious if you go into vote you're there
all these people are there you're behind
a curtain they give you one ballot you
fill it out you drop it off you leave
there's just so much there's not much
you can do with Shenanigans in fact if
you tried them they'd stop you like if I
were to say if I go into vote and I tell
them listen I have an urgent appointment
let me take my ballot and my brother
will bring it back and give it to you
filled out they'd be like no way okay
it's ridiculous right there we're not
going to allow that right of course but
think about it that's exactly what
happens with the mail-in ballot they
have these voter rolls and the voter
rolls by the way are notoriously
inaccurate by that I mean Americans move
all the time let's say you move three
times over the last 10 years your name
is going to be on all those places that
you lived and no one's taken it off even
though the DMV knows you moved the tax
people know you moved everybody knows
you moved but nobody tells the election
people
so you now can vote three times and
nobody will know the difference and and
if they send out a mail-in ballot three
Patrick Bet David Malin ballots are
going to all the places that you live
it's not all that difficult to get your
hands on these ballots so what I'm
getting at is there's the opportunity
with mail-in ballots to have fraud now
what made 2020 different was that for
the first time the mail-in ballot which
used to be a tiny part of the election
became a huge part of the election so
it's almost like the opportunity for
fraud multiplied greatly so so then if
they did that let's just say the claims
of there was above and beyond voter
fraud than usual we always have voter
fraud it's not a new thing it's
something that's been going on since day
one and this happens in all elections a
big one just took place recently in a
country that has a great soccer team but
aside from that uh uh uh with this voter
fraud that we're talking about but to
say that this is somehow some way more
than and above and beyond because of
covid so then that means midterm
shouldn't be above and beyond because
covet's pretty much gone we don't have
the shutdown right so 20 22 midterms
next week should be pretty fair as well
as 2024 because that covet excuse cannot
be used is that a fair question well
it's a little complex I would say yes I
have made no claims of the 2022 election
is in danger in any way although I do
think part of the reason for that is
that 20 million people have seen our
film and they're more aware of what
these problems are 20 million people
have seen I've seen 2 000 meals yes so
it's it's been out there it's it's the
most successful political documentary of
the last 10 years actually to be honest
since my first film which was called
2016 Obama's America that was the
previous kind of record holder this is
number two
um Michael Moore is the record holder in
documentary political documentaries of
all time but his films were made a long
time ago he's not making good films
today I mean like Roger
Roger and me was actually quite a small
film but it was very well done it put
him on the map his big film was
Fahrenheit 911. so yeah Fahrenheit 911
is the number one political documentary
of all time my Obama film is number two
this is gonna be a competitor for number
three do you and Michael Moore ever
collaborate debate discuss anything you
guys any of any relationship with each
other no we don't we've actually had a
little bit of like a social media
skirmishing but but it would actually be
really fun yeah why wouldn't you guys
have a conversation debate I don't know
maybe maybe you get someone that likes
hosting debates and figure that out I
don't know I'm just throwing that out
there to the atmosphere I would be open
to it I think it would do I mean we
could even do a Vegas so do if we did a
public event it would it would do well I
agree really fun to do I know a guy that
might be interested in hosting something
like that so yeah we'll keep you posted
well coming back to you know coming back
to 2020 2020 was an anomalous election
um in and um and uh what I want to make
a distinction between voter fraud and
election fraud and here's the
distinction if one guy says you know
um I'm gonna vote three times or I'm
going to vote on behalf of my father he
died last year but nobody knows it so
he's still on the rolls I'm going to
vote for him that's not going to tip an
election voter fraud is different than
election fraud so election fraud is
organized I'll give you an historical
example in in 1864 we had a lot of
mail-in ballots in this country for an
obvious reason all the soldiers were at
the on the battlefield so they couldn't
show up to vote so they use mail-in
ballots
and sure enough a bunch of
um Democrats in New York said let's rig
the election against Lincoln New York at
that time New York City was heavily
Democratic and so what they did is they
intercepted these soldiers ballots they
would steam them open change the vote
from Lincoln to McClellan or they would
vote the soldiers ballots who didn't
know they voted so there was a mail-in
ballot fraud scheme made possible by the
the peculiarity of the Civil War
so fast forward to 2020 2020 was sort of
the same unstable environment in which
election fraud became a real possibility
now what two thousand meals alleges is
this it alleges that there were these
left-wing non-profits in the inner city
we're not talking about throughout the
country but we're talking about key
Battleground States the urban areas
now these left-wing non-profits got a
huge infusion of liberal cash right
before the election which alone is kind
of odd because non-profit organizations
are not supposed to be involved in
partisan electioneering they all have
this tax status call 501c3 they're
supposed to they can they can
generically say guys we it's a civic
duty to vote but they can't say you got
to vote for Biden or you got to vote for
Trump they can't do that but they get
all this money and then we see on the
video you can actually see it these
mules show up with backpacks and we use
the term mule because of you know human
trafficking or sex trafficking this is
ballot trafficking the mules don't come
up with the ballots they're given these
backpacks of ballots to go drop off in
all the dropboxes and um but they get
them from these left-wing non-profits
the left-wing nonprofits go here's the
backpack the mule then goes on a kind of
a route and the reason that they go to
many dropboxes is kind of obvious if
they go to one dropbox and put in 500
votes then all the other dropboxes will
have 40 or 50 votes but suddenly 500
show up here people will be like what's
going on so they're instructed not to do
that diversification diversification in
the investment world I get it okay and
and again the combination of the cell
phone tracking and seeing them on video
is very suggestive now the debunkers
there's plenty of debunkers of our movie
and some of them have said you know Geo
tracking doesn't really work and you
can't really pinpoint these people going
to drop boxes and some of them have said
well you haven't shown us the same mule
in multiple drop boxes so there are
lines of criticism that I want to
acknowledge although I think I've
adequately I've been answering them on
my podcast I answer them in my book so
this is the debate that's been going so
so you know in the documentary it starts
off if if you guys haven't seen it
starts off Dennis Prager saying I'm I'm
not uh part of the camp I don't believe
this happened I don't believe this is
real I I think 2020 election was real
and all this stuff and you know Biden
won it fair and square and then at the
end you know it ends in a completely
different way where he's like you know
if this is what I just saw right now
everybody needs to see everybody needs
to realize what's going on anyway so so
that's that part of the story the
question I got is the following how is
it that if we have better technology
today we have all we have the kind of
insight you can get on any of these
social media apps that you've never had
access to the kind of insight to find
out what percentage is 18 to 24 24 to 30
days 35 today is male female earner
income location area country they can
get so deep in Intel that you can decide
I'm better off making this video in this
way because my audience does better when
a video like that you can really track
all of that right why do we have to do
any of this stuff well if we really use
technology today if we brought the
brightest technology folks on both ends
of the aisle okay somebody from the left
somebody on the right so say say Bezos
and musk say to take best Engineers we
have they come in and they say let's
create a technology that's a hundred
percent proven that no way in the world
can be you know cheated for anything to
happen with it why aren't we doing that
we should do that the European countries
do do that even third world countries
have been improving their election
systems so that number one they know the
result immediately there's no reason to
have days and days and days technology
is supposed to make things faster not
slower and but the reason it doesn't
happen now and the reason doesn't happen
in America is that I call it like
special logic and here's what I mean you
have things that work in every other
sphere of life but the moment you raise
them in the context of Elections you're
accused of voter suppression here's a
classic example voter ID right if you go
to the bank it's not banking suppression
to say you want to check cash your check
show me your ID it's not Airline
suppression if you show up at the
airport you want to travel show me your
ID it's normal everybody expects you to
do it uh you want to buy alcohol and on
and on it goes but in the one area of
Elections you show up with an i oh this
is going to be really scary blacks in
Hispanics aren't going to be able to
vote because they don't know where to
get an ID is ridiculous same thing with
electronic surveillance you have
electronic surveillance everywhere but
you put it in a Dropbox suddenly you'll
hear oh you're gonna scare people away
they're gonna knock they're not going to
want to vote because they're under
observation they're under observation
everywhere when they go to the mall so
when you whenever you find an argument
that only applies to this special case
Geo tracking the same nobody questions
that Geo tracking works in the January
6th if you look at the charging
documents Mr X was 20 feet outside the
front door of the capital Mr y was 20 30
feet inside the front door the Geo
tracking is assumed to be reliable yet
suddenly when we use it to track mules
going to dropboxes oh I don't know
Dinesh this technology is very new it
doesn't really work so this is this is a
clue that somebody doesn't want the
process to really to be on the up and up
that makes sense so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]